here in Florida people are only allowed
to buy their power from utilities not
from independent solar companies I'm
super excited that we're all here this
is about choice consumers having the
right to choose solar power without your
name I see that there are people here
fighting to change that we're trying to
get on the ballot next November thank
you so much I set up a meeting with
Alisa gene Schaefer a young activist
from Floridians for solar choice maybe
she can explain to me what's happening
so you guys as this coalition you're
collecting signatures on a pro solar
ballot initiative and the energy
companies how's the response been have
they started going after you yes I was
actually at a solar conference and all
of a sudden you know my phone started
blowing up and it was like what's going
on
the power companies a whole group of
them had posted a link on Twitter
basically announcing at this press
conference that well we're gonna do a
ballot initiative too and it was they
they took part of our name and they
called themselves consumers for smart
solar so basically the whole point of
that is to confuse people the utility
back initiative talks about solar choice
but doesn't actually give people any
choices so just to be super clear you
guys started a pro solar petition and
the energy companies created an anti
solar petition that looks like a pro
solar petition exactly and its sole
purpose is to trick people yes I have
just looking at the side-by-side which
one would you sign the green one
sponsored by the utilities looks pro
solar but actually does nothing to open
up the market to solar companies like
Sun run it would keep everything the
same could this actually be fooling
people
I asked Alyssa to take me canvassing for
some signatures so I could see for
myself we're gonna show you two ballot
initiatives so which one would you sign
if you wanted to see more solar in
Florida I've seen a green one you have
seen that
do you know who's behind this I have the
energy companies are Theo yeah they
don't want they don't want more solar so
they created this to trick people and
then they're paying people to talk to
you like outside of buildings it's
happening I saw you know you're standing
there looking at it sounds something
positive so I'll just do it did you
yeah that's so crazy it's eye-opening
even a Florida Supreme Court justice
wrote that the utility backed petition
was masquerading as pro solar I tried
numerous times to reach Florida Power
and Light but they declined to speak to
me